loin de s'excuser aujourd'hui reçues
productions martal combat à bord d'un
jet de combat ça fait ultra longtemps
qu'on s'est pas retrouvée tu as un jeu
de combat j'ai même que j'ai pu lire
cette phrase c'est parti on va jouer en
ligne il faut savoir que j'ai joué que
10 minutes et que je n'avais jamais joué
à un mortal kombat de ma vie recherche
d'un adversaire va se faire défoncer le
cul match trouver un nouvel set mais je
suis le chemin
3 il va me défoncer moi je prends raiden
voilà c'est seul que je connaisse c'est
parti ok donc lui par sur un pistolet
quoi et moi sur l'électricité statique
s'y mêlent premiers coups j'ai gagné hop
là c'est moi qui ai fait ça c'est
vraiment moi qui attend c'est quoi ça
elle est tellement rôle vous aux pieds
ou les mains tu coûtes mon avance bla on
aime bien tout le monde avance on a
envoyé les tristesses pas comment on
fait au plein emploi
hop hop la population mais petit ton
pull et la petite [ __ ] ça fait peur
ça fait des morts fait merveille son
[ __ ] de fusil la télé traite joue
comme ça annick elle sa part sur un
petit culty raiden oui au revoir au
revoir au décès dont 17 pas voilà donc
cet homme se met un bout de la carte et
n'arrête pas de tirer
c'est très agréable de clem fait ça
fatalities quelque chose de très grand
ok même droit d'entrée fecteau roues et
je fuis telle une fontaine de sable égal
bravo mais j'aimais pas mon père c'est
aussi un lieu ne sont bien lui obtenir
la capacité d'invoquer une chauve-souris
d'une erreur alors ça c'est génial
allez on y va à les regarde je vais
faire un crâne et gilet cra ça te fait
peur hein oh là là où j'arrive en
monture calment ok c'est parti hop là
moi aussi rires je crache des crânes hop
là alors je teste un peu les contrôles
télamon gros looser attentes autant en
plat le sable ne sache pas ce que je
fais mais je te défonce assez fine et la
défaite et salut
hop là les salles us moi je pratique le
salto arrière régulièrement voilà c'est
ma passion
blot le bon dieu soit sa taille ou aïe
aïe ouille atoll au jeu des seuils mais
la droite la plus ridicule de la planète
quoi au peuple à travers le au finish
him je crois que jean serrat oh mon dieu
oh oh je mets dans un portail de parts
et d'autres
et du coup il a attiré en ans avale
coûtant deux halls à la lah gorrite
kouachi l'emportent ils essaient jeu son
petit frère c'est sûr tu veux ta
revanche mon petit poulain j'entends ton
cri de rage aéroports son perso bétail
qui tira le bout de la map c'est
horrible non mais attends attends je
vais le rocher sur la gueule non mais
mais le mec sa vie c'est ça le mec sa
vie c'est se mettre aux coûts d'une
[ __ ] de maps et de tirer à temps il
s'appuyait sur un petit coin comme ça et
il a dompté dans les airs sans déconner
tiens voilà je te défonce mois oh là là
oh la la c'est la belle oh là là haut le
combat de merde oui aux plages te prends
je te mets des petites claques bim bam
boum au plat dans les testicules ça
c'est pas du tout faire connaître aïe
aïe aïe
est ce qu'on peut dire que c'était une
balle rebondissante finish him on l'a
défoncé oh là là assez gore
le meilleur c'est le fils du monde
il est là à aller c'est super loin dans
le délire
il est revenu principal mais c'est pas
grave s'il joue ce qu à rubin lé match
making fais-moi tomber contre un niveau
1 un adversaire un adversaire alors ok
jetons contre un niveau 45 qui a un
profil en or voilà mais c'est pas moi ça
me plaît allez c'est parti encore un mec
qui jouait avec les pistolets mais
arrêté voilà c'est parti ici mon berceau
favoris vous allez voir si on bat ce mec
qui a une image en or vraiment on passe
de la poule des poulains à la poule d
des poulets quoi [ __ ] il est le
velcade ça je suis le velcade quoi on
parle du matchmaking à la fin c'est
scandaleux sont les connais je sens
qu'il va me fâcher dès le début quand on
est premier coup
les skiffs oh là là haut je fais un truc
de fou ch pas exprès les range ton fusil
mme droit et sert à quoi il sert à rien
as tu veux te protéger mais en plaques
ou john ou coudes genoux
ce krach le bras c'est le très violent
arrête de drones ont pâti je déteste ce
[ __ ] de fusil voila voila ouais mais
regardez comment les gens peuvent aimer
jouer avec une [ __ ] pareil oh là là il
me défonce
mais attention petit permutations mais
arrête sa [ __ ] mais je vais tout aux
plats aux plats du canon et voilà il m'a
défoncé fait ça fatality pardon je sois
revanche directe ce qui à part lancé du
sable avant une carabine à plombs il
fait pas grand chose ce monsieur a bien
l'air bien là revient là tu te protège
allez hop on lui met des petits coups
allez vous en faites pas cette fois ce
temps et s'étendre à la fosse approché
par l'udf pas laissé le temps voilà ça
en attend qu'on excuse on est bien et
bien non comment comment est-ce qu'on
lance a pas comme ça ça c'était nul
rhett de lancer du sable c'est pas bien
bordel on n'en manque déjà on ne manqua
pas gâcher et banon j'esquive et aux
moines et voilà aimar ou défoncées voilà
ça sert à tout le monde ce combat parce
que façon des cardamines niveau de plus
que nous
ça fait un trou dans mon ventre c'est
bien bon vous me sens mieux comme ça
loin de toi c'est marrant l'entraînement
j'étais beaucoup plus fort quand même
hein je comprends pas mais je trouverais
ça tombe bien c'est parfait
allez on s'en fout peu importe les
persos qui prend en otage points c'est
parti on joue même perso moi je suis à
gauche heures pour info le conte se
ressemblent un peu
il est fort hope l'arrangé le temps de
mettre un petit ryan appelle à ma vie
c'est manger ok ça marche a remis ou
qu'effectivement alibaba dont la lame et
je suis nul à chier et je peux jouer à
éventuellement hop la balayette
hopla jetons pour autant moi je sais pas
comment j'ai fait ça met à tomber c'est
celle à londres à s'aplatir et d'un coup
et je me suis bien défendu et level 5
ans ne voit là c'est mal parti
pendant ce match pour expliquer cette
douloureuse défaite non olala ils vous
laissent aucun répit
oui j'adore sa manière de jouer au pl
cette saison ça c'était juste le petit
coup pour dire finie moins bien s'il te
plaît alors c'est quoi son finish à lui
a il essaie de le faire choix ou alors
justin troll aïn drôle et très bien
ravir à l'eau il le fait alors il
trônait l'ascension révolutionnaire qu
il arrete pas mais j'aime beaucoup cet
adversaire balla une botte le cul mais
j'aime bien sa manière de jouer il est
courageux lui pas comme ce qui est à moi
fusée qui sont loin à temps il a pris 1
gars qui est fait à moitié de métal déjà
je suis pas trop en confiance on va
faire ça avec le petit fait la
gymnastique partout c'est bien ça ok on
est bien on est bien on est bien à
parfait ah bah voilà mais sans fait sa
perspective c'est aussi haut et arrête
de tirer ce pas bien oui dans la jal on
n'abîme pas les plantes hop là bien là
voilà ta cg ce perso est génial je laime
voile atteindra le scorpion oh là là il
m'a bien qu on bourrine de faith des
fatals alors oui t'es quoi il va me
chercher les côtes et il les met dans la
tête et il me crack la tête mais c'est
parfait ça me plaît allez sa part sur un
barbecue il après iron man vous a vu
faire un rôle mais le travail doit
maintenant moi de jouer s'est pas posé
le réacteur aubade endroit olalala
quelle grosse blague
oh j'ai fait un truc si les je peux
jouer
calme-toi ça suffit voilà mon cou était
ridicule par portugal juste avant mais
c'est par abbaoui balas et là hop là
petit coup de tête mais il finit bien il
finit en beauté
calme-toi canaux c'est ce qu'ils disent
les spectres moi c'est grand come-back
la non elle va t'en trouves - le bel 58
encore plus haut rhin level 4 oh c'est
bon ça je suis pas prêt à détruire tout
ce qui se dresseront sur mon chemin
le feu contre la glace si un jour on
pouvait gagner ce serait formidable
attention la jeunesse j'ai un petit
utilité du congo début ils nous donnent
rien alors seulement lé derby on lui met
des coups d'épée au [ __ ] mais il
protège direct oui on l'a stoppé j'ai
pas fait exprès ac c'est sûr je suis
bloquée en position nul quoi bien jouer
sub zero là au plat au nickel eye
maillot ans en flagrant délit de dépôt
de téléportation quoi son peut lui
mettre dans le cul oui oh c'est beau
alors là c'est la belle mon gars si on
finit sur ça ce serait magnifique
ap thème mais mal
je refuse non en plus si tu n'es pas en
glace trop stylé il a plant à ses pieds
moi j'aurais bien aimé faire une épée en
feu et où la plante et dans sa tête une
petite revanche mon cher ami adversaires
il va dit un teigneux dégage ouais ben
wallace shawn jazz à la fois bon et ben
voilà les gens c'est déjà la fin de
cette vidéo sur mortal kombat j'espère
si vous a plu c'est qu'à nice tpm et la
vidéo comme d'habitude je veux un jour
qu'on refasse une vidéo sur mortal
kombat quand jour et du style quand
j'aurai plus de 1000 heures de jeu la
sao rien au centre de tri dans une
prochaine vidéo tient deux bis